ahora que tenemos la distancia
explícitamente como una función del
ángulo de que lanzamos el objeto vamos a
usar algo de cálculo para encontrar el
ángulo óptimo el ángulo que nos maximiza
unos optimizan nuestra distancia
ya que solo nos interesan los ángulos de
0 a 90 grados vamos a restringir los
vamos a utilizar esto para
ángulos que van de 0 de manera que teta
es menor o igual a 0 pero mayor o igual
a 0 y también teta es menor o igual a 90
grados
para tener una idea de lo que vamos a
hacer con el cálculo recuerden que
cuando ustedes toman una derivada están
encontrando la pendiente de una curva
si nosotros graficar amos esta función
en este rango lo de 0 a 90 grados
tendríamos
nuestra
nuestro eje
de la distancia en función del ángulo
theta
y nuestro eje
el ángulo tech
donde tenemos que va
desde cero grados
hasta 90 grados
entonces si ustedes graficarán esto les
quedaría una curva más o menos más o
menos así
entonces si queremos encontrar la
pendiente de una curva la pendiente
instantánea de una curva vamos a buscar
la derivada y bueno si queremos
encontrar aquel ángulo en el que en este
intervalo nos dé la máxima distancia
bueno cuál sería la máxima distancia
esta de aquí tenemos que queremos
encontrar este ángulo
que nos dé una distancia máxima o una
distancia óptima
estancia
óptima
bueno lo que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar aquella pendiente dónde va lo
como es la pendiente en este punto pues
es plana la pendiente aquí
0 así que tenemos que encontrar un
ángulo en cuya la derivada de esta curva
sea igual a 0
bueno entonces tenemos que encontrar la
derivada de nuestra curva y así con eso
vamos a encontrar el ángulo misterioso
en el cual tendremos nuestra distancia
máxima máxima bueno vamos a ver que la
derivada de esta función la derivada de
esta función con respecto al ángulo
es igual bueno asumiendo que la s y la g
son constantes y las podemos dejar igual
aquí no tenemos que preocuparnos por
ellas por ellas en este momento 2s
cuadrada sobre g
vamos a aplicar la regla de la
multiplicación de derivadas en la que es
esta regla es la derivada de este
término
por el segundo término más la derivada
del segundo término por el primer
término entonces tenemos que la derivada
del costero
- seno del ángulo
por el segundo término que es el seno
del ángulo
más
la segunda
por la derivada de la primera y la
derivada del seno también es el coche no
detecta entonces para hacer esto un poco
más claro vamos a indicar que está de
este término
la derivada del coche no detecta con
respecto a teta
este término y este es la derivada del
seno detecta con respecto al ángulo teta
bueno podemos simplificar esto de manera
que nos queda
que nuestra derivada
de esta distancia con respecto a teta es
igual a nuestra constante
2 s cuadrada sobre g
se lo detecta por si uno detecta es
igual a menos
seno cuadrado detecta más
consignó cuadrado por coser para los
cocineros detecta por cocina de teta es
igual al coseno cuadrado de teta
y ya que queremos saber
la distancia máxima o sea el ángulo en
el que esta función no es igual a cero
bueno entonces vamos a despejar teta
tenemos que este ángulo bueno esta parte
constante podemos dividir ambos términos
de esta ecuación entre este
elemento lo que nos dejaría bueno
cualquier o entre cualquier cosa sigue
siendo 0 nos queda menos el cuadrado del
ángulo más 50 cuadrado del ángulo teta
es igual a 0
y bueno podríamos también hacer ya que
en este intervalo de 0 90 grados estos
elementos nos van a van a ser positivos
o vamos a poder tener los las raíces
positivas podemos sacar la raíz cuadrada
de estos términos pero vamos a hacer
ahorita otra manera para despejar
vamos a dividir todo entre
bueno podemos
sumar seno cuadrado de tete en ambos
lados y nos queda coserlo cuadrado de
tener es igual a cero
cuadrado detecta dividimos ambos
términos entre el coseno cuadrado de
teta
entonces nos queda el coseno cuadrado
detecta entre este coseno cuadrado
es igual al seno cuadrado de teta entre
coseno cuadrado de teta este término
pues bueno es igual a 1 y podemos
simplificar esto viendo que el seno
perdón si que el seno cuadrado de
detecta entre cocina cuadrado que estaba
hace lo mismo que él se lo detecta entre
jose no detecta al cuadrado y puedo
sacar la raíz cuadrada de ambos términos
la raíz cuadrada de 1 es igual a la raíz
cuadrada del seno cuadrado de 0 de teta
cocina de teta al cuadrado
entonces me queda que se no detecta
entre cocina de teta y en la raíz
cuadrada de 1 pues sigue siendo uno y si
vemos seno de tete entre cocina de teta
esto
es igual a 1 y esto tenemos que también
es la tangente
entonces tenemos que 1 nuestra tangente
del ángulo texta es igual a 1 si
queremos conocer el ángulo entonces
vamos a multiplicar ambos términos por
la tangente inversa o el arco tangente
de manera que el arco tangente
de uno va a ser igual a el ángulo teta y
esta es una manera elegante de decir que
el ángulo teta es aquel ángulo cuya
tangente va a ser 1 y puede no ser su
calculadora o sus tablas o su memoria
para resolver esto y descubrirán que el
arco tangente de 1 es igual a 45 grados
o si trabajan o si quieren trabajar con
radiales será igual a pi entre 4
radiales
entonces bueno cuál va a ser la
distancia máxima si usamos este ángulo
mágico que ya encontramos que es de 45
grados bueno regresamos a nuestra
fórmula original
y vamos a sustituir estos elementos que
ya encontramos
sabemos que luego escribir por acá el
seno de 45 grados es igual a raíz de 2
entre 2 y también sabemos que el cose lo
de 45 grados también es igual a raíz de
2 entre 2
entonces
sustituyendo esto en nuestra fórmula la
distancia
a 45 grados
es igual a 2 s cuadrada / g
por el coche no detecta que el cocina de
té es raíz de dos
entre dos bueno con cocina de 45 grados
y que el seno de 45 grados es igual a
raíz de dos
entre dos bueno es multiplicamos dos por
la raíz de dos por raíz de dos y nos
queda que esto es igual a 2
este 2 se cancela con este este otro 2
se cancela con este y nos queda que la
distancia óptima va a ser a s cuadrada
entre g
asumiendo que no hay ninguna resistencia
del aire entonces si ustedes me dijeran
que ese es igual
no sé digamos
10 metros
por segundo el ángulo ya que encontramos
que es igual a 45 grados
y me dicen que en su gravedad es de 10
metros por segundo al cuadrado entonces
la distancia óptima va a ser igual a 10
al cuadrado que va a ser 100 metros
cuadrados entre segundo al cuadrado
entre la aceleración de la gravedad que
es 10 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
estos segundos al cuadrado se van este
metro cuadrado se va con este metro 100
entre 10 me queda que va a ser igual
10 metros la distancia óptima